il était temps parce que on annonce un
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai et que
pour les élus locaux pour qu'on puisse
organiser
il nous reste plus que sept jours ouvrés
à peu près donc les mesures qui ont été
annoncées sont évidemment les bienvenues
malgré tout il n'y a pas trop de
nouveautés sans l'aide des élus locaux
et sans les élus de terrain l'état ne
peut rien faire donc c'est à aussi
l'état de nous accompagner donc on a
quand même une
j'allais dire une petite bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on aura au moins 50 % du coût
des masques que nous avons achetés pour
le grand public qui sera pris en charge
donc on attend les détails après moi je
reste quand même inquiet sur la reprise
de scolaires ans le 11 même si on se
prépare déjà depuis quelques jours
quelques semaines en interne c'est
l'accueil des enfants les flux les
gestes barrière la formation du
personnel municipal les produits à
utiliser est ce qu'on sera en capacité
et aussi la responsabilité qui est la
mienne qui est celle des élus locaux qui
n'a pas été abordée